i hate intros mob psycho 100 season 2
episode 1.
we kick things off with reagan and mob
going out to a farmer who hires them to
take care of a spirit on his farm
the spirit wriggle wriggle gets into a
fight with mob after hearing they
planned on exercising him
mob uses his powers to control plants
and defeats the spirit jump back on over
to school where kamuro
shinji who in season 1 framed some of
the other students and because of that
he resigns as the student council
president
mazito wants to take advantage of this
opportunity to help mob develop by
becoming the new student council
president she convinces him to run by
saying that if he won
tsubami might like him he agrees but
this goes pretty badly when he tries to
make a speech to the student body on why
they should elect him
he freezes up and ends up not being able
to get out a single word
after the failed speech he finishes last
and kumuro is re-elected
mob was filling a little bit down until
he gets a love letter from a girl named
emmy who says that she admired his
courage despite not being able to say
anything during his speech
the two start dating and emmy tells him
about how she likes to write books and
has him read one of them
a week into dating and after some pretty
good times emmy reveals that she asked
him out on a dare and didn't actually
want to date him she leaves him behind
but later mob runs into her and her
so-called friends who are making fun of
the fact that she had written a story
they go on to tear up the story while
emmy acts like it doesn't bother her
mob knows that she was just putting on a
brave face and it meant a lot to her so
he goes to pick up the pieces
the girls stick around long enough to
kind of poke fun at him but leave
shortly after while emmy decides to stay
behind and help
despite getting most of the pieces a
gust of wind nearly blows them all away
so mob is forced to use his powers to
reassemble the paper before the pieces
were lost
revealing himself as an expert
this good deed also scored some major
brownie points because tsubami just so
happened to be nearby and seems a little
hot and bothered by his generosity
episode 2. well out trying to find some
more work since business was a little
slow mob
and reagan run into a rival psychic in
shinra bonshimaru
both reagan and shinra get into a mini
competition for a job when a lady comes
to them and explains that there is a
spirit next to her which mob can confirm
now that she knows they're the real deal
she goes on to ask for their help in
dealing with some nearby urban legends
called human face
dog dash granny the red ranco and the
dragger
reagan and shinra agree to work together
but when they split up reagan asks
dimple to follow shinra to make sure
nothing bad happens to him
well being mistaken for a pervert
hitting on little kids shinra ends up
running into the red raincoat who
supposedly according to the urban legend
loves to bathe in children's blood
it turns out he's just creepy in a
different way than the urban legend had
initially thought he's really just an
actual pervert who likes flashing little
kids shinra is a white knight in the
face of pedophilia so he goes to
apprehend the red raincoat causing him
to flee
and leading him on a chase meanwhile mob
and reagan disprove the human face
dog urban legend which was really just a
dog that kids drew on back on over to
shinra who catches up to the red
raincoat but ends up getting tasered and
falls unconscious
when he comes too he sees the red
raincoat being taken away by another
spirit which is the dragger urban legend
he tries to save him but ends up getting
attacked by the spirit instead
forcing dimple to step in and save his
life dimple then goes on to call reagan
and let them know that they're in
trouble
the dragger continues trying to kill
them but dimple manages to keep shinra
alive until
mob reaches them and defeats the spirit
the red ranco is arrested leaving just
dash granny as the last urban legend to
deal with
mob and reagan managed to hunt down the
culprit but it's really just an old lady
running so mob can't exercise her
episode 3 reagan had launched a website
so that he can get more work
the website is going really well until
he gets a client who asks him to curse
another man
at first reagan refuses but after
getting tired of dealing with the man's
persistence he gives him a fake charm
promising that if he carries it around
eventually something bad will happen to
the man later on we get some filler
content
when mob and reagan go to exercise a
woman's apartment turns out there
is no spirit but her neighbor was using
an out of body experience to spy on the
girl because he was in love with her
naturally this doesn't go over too well
with her and he ends up getting arrested
not too sure what they charged him with
but for the sake of the story we won't
question it reagan is then hired by some
college students to protect them while
they attempt to get some sort of spirit
selfie in a haunted area
nothing ends up happening so they refuse
to pay reagan a mob and drive off
stranding the two of them there
more filler content ensues with mob
getting bullied and everyone coming to
his rescue to put the bullies in their
place
back on over to the college students who
then come back to reagan and want to
re-hire him because they caught a spirit
in one of their pictures
and the thought of it existing is
bothering them everyone returns to the
haunted area but they learn that the
spirits are actually a peaceful family
that just want to spend a little bit
more time together before they cross
over
mob doesn't want to kill the innocent
spirits but the college kids are
insistent that they do it dample steps
in
and antagonizes the father spirit in an
attempt to make him lose control go into
a rage and attack
the spirit refuses and maintains that
they're not a threat to anyone
proving that they can be trusted mob is
extremely conflicted at the thought of
having to fight either the family of
spirits
or the students because he values them
both equally which is something that
reagan hadn't realized until then
reagan then goes on to perform an
imitation exorcism to appease the
students without exercising the spirits
yey episode 4 reagan gets a new job
offer from a ceo named
masashi asagari who is extremely wealthy
naturally he jumps on this opportunity
with ma because of the potentially high
payout when they arrive at his estate
they find a number of
other psychics that he's hired also this
includes shinra
as well as his master kieran johto who
are both part of the sun psychic union
they are all asked by the ceo to
exercise his daughter minori who was
apparently possessed the spirit
responsible for her possession is
recognized by dimple as
keiji mogami who while alive was also a
psychic
dimple warns of the others that mogami
was a powerful psychic that nearly
killed
and absorbed him in order to become a
powerful spirit after he died
dimple had managed to escape but his
friends weren't so lucky and were killed
by mogami
now that mogami was dead he took on his
final form as the powerful spirit that
he wanted to become
mob quickly realizes that mogami is too
strong and he can't get him out of
minori's body he changes up his tactics
to take a page out of the peeping tom's
handbook and make himself have an
out-of-body experience
he then goes inside minori's body to
chase the spirit out while dimple stays
behind to possess his body and protect
it
once inside mob confronts mogami who
explains that they are in a mental world
that he can bend to his will
he pretends to be injured by mob but
then strips him of his powers and
defeats him
after mob has been incapacitated mogami
explains that the psychic power's
potency comes from the emotions of the
user
the more negative the emotions are the
stronger the psychic powers
in the last scene mogami bends the
mental world to replicate an exact copy
of mob's life with the only exception
being that mob has no powers
friends or family episode 5
mob lives inside the mental world for
what he perceives to be 6 months
even though in the real world it's only
been 30 minutes just casually ripping
off inception
since he has no powers he is
relentlessly bullied by the people in
his life including minori who was placed
into the world as a transfer student
his brother and friends are strangers to
him so when he gets picked on this time
around nobody comes to his aid
we then get a little bit of backstory on
kogami he was a psychic like mob and
when his mother got sick he decided to
use his power to kill people for money
in order to pay for her medical
treatment
after she died she became an evil spirit
and blamed him for her dying
the logic being that the evil deeds that
he was performing in order to keep her
alive began to surround him and
ended up plaguing her after learning
this he decides to commit suicide in
order to become the most
powerful evil spirit but this time
around he's not going to think about
anybody else he's just going to focus on
himself the bullying continues as mob
gets targeted for trying to help out a
stray cat
mogami then steps in trying to convince
mob to stop letting people get away with
whatever they want
his goal is to turn mob into one of his
sympathizers and help him punish the
people in the real world
meanwhile dimple decides this is
probably taking too long so he goes
inside minori's body also to find mob
but back on over to mob who is finally
giving his powers back so that he can
fight back against minori and his
bullies
just before he gives into his negative
emotions and kills one of the boys
dimple shows up to talk him down at
first he doesn't even remember dimple or
anybody from the real world for that
matter
but as soon as he hears zobami's name
everything comes rushing back
mugami then goes on to explain that the
people inhabiting this world
are some of the evil spirits that he had
absorbed while he was alive
they all began to attack mob forcing him
to fight them off while also trying to
save minori he manages to defeat kogami
in the process but by doing this he
releases all of the spirits inside of
him who all proceed to attack mob
this ends up overpowering and destroying
mob's body so he enters the unknown
power level and
uses this to destroy the spirits as well
as the entire mental world
mob then wakes up in his real body and
as mogami is leaving minori's body he is
immediately captured by matsuo who
renames him to pudding chan
minori admits that the horrible person
she was to him in the mental world is
actually the same way she acts in the
real world
but she does realize how mean she was so
she panics plays the victim card
and breaks down crying while
simultaneously begging for his
forgiveness
he forgives her mostly because she
helped him realize that people are
capable of changing
episode 6 mob has been making huge
progress in his social circles and his
fitness
his progress is kind of being stunted by
reagan though who continuously calls him
a way to help with his exorcisms
him and mob eventually get into a huge
fight because mod realizes that it's
possible
reagan could just be using him for his
powers the two stop talking for a while
and mob focuses on his friendships while
reagan continues to work alone
on reagan's birthday he finds himself
alone and unhappy with his life but this
makes him determined to turn things
around
even without the help of mob he starts
to focus on his work uploading videos on
how to exercise spirits
teaching people so that they aren't
tricked by frauds and giving them just
general life advice
his reputation begins to spike and he
soon becomes known as the seasoning
city's bro
he gets so popular in fact that he gets
an offer to go on to a tv show for
psychics which he agrees to in order to
get even more popular
the problem is that he is being set up
by kieran johto to expose reagan as a
fraud
this is all because at the mansion
kogami had possessed shoutout in the
fighting and so
reagan needs him in the face to defend
himself johto felt kind of disrespected
by that for whatever reason so now he's
targeting reagan
episode 7 well on the show reagan is of
course quickly exposed as a fraud who
doesn't have psychic powers he is
humiliated
and everyone in his life starts turning
against him because there's a constant
barrage of reporters camping outside of
his place to get a story he finally
agrees to just have a press conference
once the conference gets underway he
inadvertently starts claiming that they
have no proof that he doesn't have
psychic powers
one of the reporters asks why are you
even in the psychic business
this question procs a flashback to three
years ago when he was first approached
by mob
at first he just wanted to help mob
because he thought he was dealing with
normal kid problems i.e depression low
confidence that all changes though once
he realizes that mob
actually has psychic powers and could
exercise spirits thinking about all of
this and the present reagan starts to
realize maybe he was just using mob
but he does really care about him so
this makes him regret it once he had
realized all of this he has a moment of
clarity and decides that he wants to try
and reach out to mob so he looks into
the camera and says you've grown up
the whole building starts to shake and
all of the cameras and equipment starts
to hover
of course this makes the media think
that it was reagan doing
all of this and he just responds that
they should find a new story
afterwards while walking back he
conveniently runs into mob
and dimple they ultimately make up
because mob still believes that reagan
is
and always has been a good person
episode 8
mob makes a promise to himself that if
he competes in the upcoming marathon and
makes it into the top 10 then he'll
impress
tsubomi and finally have the courage to
ask her out he pushes himself to his
limits at the marathon but only finishes
in 74th place before passing out
back on over to reagan who gets asked
for relationship
advice by one of subalmi's friends while
there subomi realizes that mob might
have some sort of connection with regan
because of a picture in his office
anyways over the ritsu who is at home
with his parents when he hears a knock
at the door
when he answers it he finds show suzuki
who we met in season 1
and is the son of the leader of claw we
don't see what happens but when mob
arrives at his home later on he sees it
burning down
he goes through the flames to find his
family and comes across some burned
bodies causing him to lose control of
his emotional state
in the last scene
episode 9. mob is on the verge of having
a complete meltdown thinking that his
family is dead until
dimple is able to calm him down by
saying that the bodies were fakes
he channels his senses to find nearby
espers and runs into two scars from the
main branch of claw who were looking for
him
neither of them have any idea what
happened to his family so he disposes of
them
after that he is picked up by koyama and
sakurai who take him to meet up with
other espers from season one
this includes the former seventh
division scars who band together after
the division was shut down due to their
failures the whole gang seems to be
there because there are also espers from
the awakening lab and reagan they
discussed the fact that claw is planning
on launching an attack on the city so
they were targeting espers who might get
in their way
reagan helps mob calm down saying that
he feels like his family is safe so mob
immediately falls unconscious
no zomo hot to worry a member of claws
ultimate 5 which is their most elite
fighters broadcasts tochiro suzuki
across all devices declaring that claw
is going to go to war with the world
and the city we then get a look at show
who is actually working with ritsu to
stop his father
mob's parents are fine and were sent
away to a resort to keep them
out of it sho was also responsible for
the fake bodies at mob's place hoping to
give mob
a reason to fight against claw one of
the espers in claw joseph
is actually working undercover for the
government and tries to set a mutiny in
motion
amongst the claw ranks this is easily
taken care of and he gets handled by
members of the ultimate five torture
the leader of claw orders ryoshimazaki
another member of the five to abduct the
prime minister
hanazawa happens to be passing by and
tries to stop this but he gets his ass
handed to him by shimozaki
and the prime minister is taken hostage
in the last scene
episode 10. we see sho and ritsu
fighting their way through club members
to get to the tower where claw is
launching their attacks from so sho can
confront his dad
hanazawa and the others decide they need
to fight back also so they start
planning their assault with half the
team causing a distraction
allowing the other half to infiltrate
the tower this gets negated by shimazaki
who finds the infiltration team and
quickly defeats them
reagan stays behind with mob and dimple
since mob is still unconscious and they
are confronted by a team of espers sent
to kill mob
reagan uses a spray to put most of the
men to sleep but the five-member hiroshi
shibata turns into a rampaging maniac
forcing dimple to take control of mob's
body and run
his original plan was to flee but then
he sees tsubami could be in danger while
passing by in a crowd forcing him to
fight back
dimple gets smacked so hard that he is
forced from mob's body which is sent
flying through the air
mob is conveniently caught by members of
the improvement club who try to stand up
against shibata to protect mob
shockingly this doesn't go so well and
they all get manhandled relatively
easily
soon it's only musashi left to protect
mob so dipple possesses him to give him
the strength necessary to fight back
against shibata they do manage to buy
enough time for mob to regain
consciousness and then once he's back in
the fight he takes care of shabbata for
good
episode 11 mob is making his way to the
tower when he ends up getting into a
fight with claw members and plant boy
matsuo sees him and feels like he needs
help so he steps in with his spirits to
fight
in the fighting the flask that contains
mogami is broken and he is let loose
mogami still isn't super happy and
quickly defeats minigishi without any
real effort then disappears without a
trace
so just keep in mind for future seasons
that he's still out there somewhere
shimazaki also cuts off sho and ritsu
but allow
show to go on ahead in order to focus on
his fight with ritsu
ritsu isn't doing so hot and just before
he is killed the entire gang of espers
show up with hanazawa to help fight
against shimazaki
we'll put that fight on pause so that we
can jump on over to show who confronts
his father he tries on unleashing all
the power he has been storing up for
three months in hopes of defeating his
father with one blow
that all sounds good or whatever but the
problem is that his father has the same
power and he's been storing his up for
20 years meaning that show doesn't
really have a chance
meanwhile there's an epic fight between
shimazaki and the rest of the espers
where they quickly find out shimazaki
is still out of their league shimazaki
is then distracted by mob's approaching
presence allowing reagan to sneak up on
him and land a quick flurry on him
after realizing how strong mob is he
decides that he's going to dip because
he doesn't really want any part of that
fight mob leaves the others behind and
goes to the tower alone with dimples
saying that they will just get in his
way
episode 12. mob runs into katsuya
sarazawa another member of the five and
we get some backstory on how he was a
shut-in he never felt comfortable
leaving his room
until the boss recruited him into claw
after that
he saw totoro as kind of a savior figure
so he dedicated himself entirely to the
cause and claw but back to the present
him
and mob get into a fight where mob
proves that he understands his
loneliness and sadness by sharing his
emotions with him
mob convinces him that toy true is just
using him and he doesn't actually care
about him the way he thinks and after
realizing that he gives up on fighting
bob
over the dorychiro who explains to show
that he also has the power to transfer
psychic powers between people
and has been lending his power out to
claw members to fight
now that they've been defeated they
don't really need it anymore so he
reclaims all of his powers so he can
fight at full strength to the entrance
of mob who shows up and tries to talk
him down
that'd be pretty anticlimactic if they
just came to a diplomatic resolution so
instead he attacks mob this doesn't go
too well for mob so reagan is forced to
step
in and try and save mob and then that
forces sabrez always to step
in to save reagan because obviously he
was never going to do anything relevant
sarah's house show and reagan get back
to ground level with the rest of the
espers
now that they're all clear of the tower
this is mob's queue that he can go all
out episode 13. with mob fighting at
full power toy shiro realizes that he's
gonna have to fight at full power as
well in order to keep
up this causes him to lose control over
his power and he turns into a giant time
bomb that will destroy the city
ma prepares to sacrifice himself in
order to contain the explosion and
protect the others
he then gets another idea to transfer
some of the power from toitro into
himself
in order to mitigate the explosion at
least preserving most of the city
and the people nearby both mob and
toeitro
survive the explosion antoitrio goes on
to apologize to sho for being kind of
[ __ ] crazy and tried to take over the
world and then he is taken into custody
mob had some broccoli seeds in his
pocket before the explosion and his
power caused the seeds to grow into a
massive broccoli known as the divine
tree
don't know how relevant that's gonna be
but the more you know in the last scene
we see all of the characters are getting
re-acclimated to their lives
sarizawa ends up getting a makeover from
reagan so that he can start working
at the spirits and such consultation
office with him and mob
i'm going to be doing the feature season
and you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the mob psycho 100 recaps
in the playlist on the right side you
can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is
outros